we um go ahead or give it another minute
or so
i think you can go ahead and get started
if you could start the recording
yeah i started it already yeah
okay good morning everyone nice to see
you all back
i hope you all had a good evening good
night good morning i'm not sure all
different time zones
um and i hope you're all ready to
look at life in three dimensions
um so today uh what i'm gonna focus on
is how looking at things
in three dimensions uh suddenly gives
you a completely
different picture about what you've been
thinking about a protein
and how that visualization in three
dimensions
actually is integral to the function of
all of these proteins
right so again uh like all like
yesterday please
um feel free to um you know send in your
questions
um ask your questions anytime uh you can
interrupt me at any point
again it will be i hope you all i have
had your coffee
and all you all have all the energy to
uh interact correct so i'm looking
forward to a very interactive session
again
and let's get started so right so first
i just want
to briefly um look at
what we did yesterday um
do you all remember anything that came
to your mind
of what we did yesterday we actually
defined bioinformatics and databases
uh do you all remember what the
definition or a simple definition
of bioinformatics that we finally came
up with
any recollection of what we talked about
yes absolutely integration of all ohmic
terms
fantastic um and then we actually
looked at all the key players in the
field of bioinformatics
and i'm sure you all remember one figure
whom we defined as the father and mother
of bioinformatics
do you remember her name
any fantastic wow you guys are fantastic
so margaret dehoff right
so every day i want you to remember a
few things and hopefully that stays in
your mind right so that
it rings a bell when when you are asked
about this
so we also talked about sequence
explosion big data
and all of those things genome
sequencing when did it all start
why is all different aspects of the
genome important
not that one aspect of the genome is
more important than the other
now we actually have to focus on the
pretty much the entire genome right and
why
it's important there are lots of
different things
also all the challenges we're facing
today
uh because of this explosion in data
while we have these challenges but we
also have solutions to these challenges
right so we discussed a little bit of
the solutions to these challenges
without this explosion of data of course
it's a good thing
although it's challenging it's a good
thing
because it's going to keep us all busy
for the next um you know
20 30 years or 40 years or whatever
whatever may come right
so we're all we all have something to
contribute
to so the explosion so before i start
today's lecture are there any questions
that's lingering in your head from
yesterday that you want me to clarify
before we get started if you have any
questions
uh i'll just wait for a second or two to
see if you have any questions so that we
can actually move forward
or we can actually you can keep those
questions and we can actually discuss it
at the very end
of the lecture i'll i'll hopefully leave
some room for
questions of course we also talked about
human genome project hackmap project
end code project genome word association
studies
um where can we access recorded sessions
i'm sure beepsha will
send you an email
uh okay so um so role of big data
so when you look at all of these
different projects that we talked about
human genome project have my project
encode and all of these things
what is this that came out as if you had
to summarize everything that you would
we have learnt about all of these
projects and
and the role of these projects and um
what is it something that actually is a
take home from all of these projects
other than
we're drowning in data right it's
contributed and it also has contributed
to the way we look at diseases
so is there anything that's just coming
out of these that
you did not know that you were actually
shocked to actually talk to them
uh starting to map the data that's
correct there you know so
you actually are beginning to map the
data begin to understand and also for me
the overwhelming thing the effect enough
of medicine that's right so bettering
personalized medicine pharmacogenomics
that's
that's fantastic jeffrey um yes that's
pretty much what it is right so
we cannot assume that one drug is going
to work for all of us
and you cannot assume that because we
are 99.9
or 99.9 percent similar in our genomes
that we are identical we are actually
not in fact even identical twins are not
identical right so
so we are learning a lot but it's a good
thing that we're having so much data
because we can figure out it's like a
puzzle right
i'm sure all of you love to put all of
these thousand piece puzzles and all of
those it's pretty much like a puzzle
we're all trying to figure things out
right so now i'm going to take you uh oh
this is a repetition right so today our
learning objectives is going to be
looking
in three dimensions what can structure
tell us uh what is how is structure an
integral
part of without structure it's why is it
integral to understanding functions
of all of these things and how one
single mutation in a protein sequence
can affect its three-dimensional
structure in a way it changes its
behavior
completely and as i told you yesterday
anything that
any change in a gene it gets personal if
it gets personal that means
it affects us right so which means
that's what we call
if it's not normal then we call it's a
disease right so that's pretty much what
we're going to focus on today
right so introduction to protein
structure right
so i'm sure all of you have seen all of
these pretty pictures
right and i must tell you that
a huge amount of work goes behind
before we can actually see this pretty
picture right that's my
expertise that's what i'm trained in and
so i've gone through the pain and
suffering of
actually determining the
three-dimensional structures of proteins
right so what is this this is the first
structure of protein that was solved
and that's something one and nobel prize
as well any guesses
of what this structure
is just fill in the blanks
anything the whole
um yes you're right it's alpha hylissus
is that what you're meaning
or just the blue yes but what is
the name of this protein um
this is where you kind of guess
it starts i'm going to give you a clue
it starts with the
m
anything that's actually very important
protein in our bodies
absolutely chandrani and chandani is
correct it's it's actually myoglobin
correct this was the first structure of
a protein that was actually solved
and because it was so important actually
it won a nobel prize
right and then um it was
um shared by max perutz and john kendra
in the 60s long time ago
in chemistry and it was divided between
these two right this was the first time
and you can actually imagine the awe
that people had when they actually
solved this
structure right and those days we're
talking about
50 years ago how our structure is
actually
solved they're actually built literally
built
which is called the wire model and if
any of you come to
washington dc and you have an
opportunity to go to the national
institutes of health they actually have
the wire model
there and this is how scientists used to
measure
angles and all of those things right can
you imagine how it was but it was very
precise
and now we don't even know how what are
what you know what effort we have to put
in to get a structure
now this is all the different nobel
prizes
that have people i want for structural
biology
and you can see pretty much almost every
other year there is a
nobel laureate who has solved the
structure of something so
this just tells you how structures are
very important right without structures
understanding functions is hard right in
essence
if you want a nobel prize study
structural biology right i'm not kidding
uh of course all the easy protein
structures have already been solved
so all the ones that are there are all
very very difficult proteins
so any one of you interested in
structural biology i would urge you to
pursue structural biology because you
know we find answers to these things
of course part of it is a joke as well
right so why
else would we study a protein structure
rather than of course
winning a nobel prize right protein
structure
so when you look at this structure
and when you look at this structure
right i'm going to take this
off here so when you look at this
structure
and when you look at this structure do
they look similar to you
to your eyes the hillises
are here yes of course yes betsy it
actually right
this actually looks very similar similar
right
the structures but when you look at when
you align the sequences
they're only 21 identical
when you do an alignment of these two
protein sequences
isn't that shocking two proteins that
have
about 20 percent in sequence similarity
or identity
still can have the same structure right
these are different enzymes
right so what we assume we make a lot of
assumptions in science right
so what you we will say is that
in order to understand functions even
when the sequence similarity is very
very low
to find the relatedness between two
sequences
and if they have the same function we
just cannot just do a blast
and look at them and say oh my god
they're only 20 in sequence similarity
that means they are not related to each
other
which means they probably don't do the
same function
and also they don't actually have the
same you know they do
they are different but that's not what
it means so that's why
in order to understand similarities
between two
sequences even if their similarity
sequence identities is slow we need to
have three dimensional structures
so you can actually discover relatedness
between two proteins
that are not similar at sequence but at
the structure level right
so why study protein structure als
although it is a lot of work
and a lot of pain and suffering it helps
us to understand function
right without protein structures we
can't understand functions
precisely now you all know this was
again watson and trick
they actually got the three-dimensional
structure and of course i have to
also mention rosalind franklin right
um they actually found out the structure
of dna
three-dimensional structure of dna just
imagine if we didn't understand dna
structure today
we won't be doing any of the things
we're doing today because we won't even
know what pairs with what and we
wouldn't even know the stacking effects
we wouldn't even know how dna binds to
proteins we wouldn't even know anything
right so that was a
landmark and now these are the three
people who actually won the nobel prize
uh
for that physiology and medicine right
now again
why else would we study protein
structure we will study protein
structure
to understand fundamental fundamentals
of cell machineries like protein
translation
how are proteins made in the cell how do
proteins actually work
do you remember any protein that is
involved in
the whole whole process of translation
can you think of any protein that's
integral to the whole mechanism of
translation
do you know where proteins are made in
the cell any guesses
there are yes that's correct ribosome my
goodness
cytoplasm absolutely so
ribosome correct many of you have said
ribosome absolutely
it's actually where it's one of the most
important measuring
in the cells are there any proteins that
are part of the ribosome
and the whole translation machinery
that's actually very important
what actually recognizes your mrna
of course there are lots of enzymes
that's correct jeffrey there are lots of
enzymes dna polymerases and all of those
things right
so this is this three-dimensional
structure of ribosome you know it's
humongous
you know how many years it took them to
actually come to this high-resolution
structure to look at
atomic details of every single atom
in the whole ribosome missionary it took
them actually 20 30 years
to actually come up with the structure
and the minute we found we have the
structure we can explain how the trna
binds
what is actually what is the role of the
rna component of these ribosomes
what are all these different proteins
actually doing
exactly we were able to under we were
able to explain the entire process of
translation
and of course ribosome we also the
biggest lesson we learned
is ribosome is a ribozyme
which means it's an enzyme right so
there are three trna sites they were
we knew that trna played a big role but
we just didn't know how
where the trna is bound and how all of
these different sites actually
one went to the next and all of those
things right so
based on the three-dimensional structure
we were able to exactly locate where the
trna binds what are the different
interactions and all of those things
and these are the three people who
actually won
the nobel prize actually he passed away
unfortunately last year but
um they're all there so then why else
would we study protein structure we
study protein structure to understand
protein channels
work as they make up 30 percent of our
cells and membrane proteins and channels
they form all these transporters
and all of those things right again um
roderick mckinnon he actually figured
out
exactly how things in the cell
move in and out of the membrane right in
and out
without the three-dimensional atomic
resolution and atomic positions of every
single atom we would deny we would not
know exactly
how these channels work and how these
actually sit in a membrane
right this is the potassium channel and
he figured out exactly
what every single atom also means you
know i run an
entire course on all of this so as you
know
i'm just going giving you just a glimpse
of what
structural biology can actually help
right so it's a lot there
right so we'll just giving you a little
flavor of what structures can help and
you understand also it helps us to
understand enzyme mechanisms
how peptidases work for example have you
all heard of peptidases
do you all know what peptidases actually
do
just based on this peptide no okay
so does this give you a hint
cleaves yeah it actually cleaves but it
cleaves specifically
yes exactly peptide bonds correct
fantastic you guys are amazing
so this is peptidases means it cleaves
peptide bonds right so
any enzyme it actually uh works only on
one or two amino acids right it just
leaves something uh it breaks down
something that's correct
and all of those things right so how did
we understand
exactly which bond is getting cleaved
and how is it getting cleaved which i
saw that exactly to the
details of an atomic to the atom
and to the bond it actually helps you
understand structures
and also structures helps you understand
learn about evolution you look further
back in evolutionary history and figure
out how
i actually gave you an example of how
two proteins
that have very low sequence identities
had the similar structures
here i'm talking to you about two
different
protein structures but they actually do
the same function
right so we have conservative evolution
and you know we have different kinds
where actually they
come together of course i don't want to
confuse you because that's
evolution itself is another topic for
discussions
uh we can do it another time right so
again it helps us to understand
does it have this binds to the same
ligand this also binds to the same
ligand what is common between these two
are
they are both dependent on plp right
periodoxyl phosphates right and now
again
the amino acid amino transferases and l
branch
chain amino acid amino transferases they
also have the same structures
right so without the structure we
wouldn't actually even know
that the amino acid amino transferase
and
l-brands chain amino acid a minor type
are actually the same
which means they do the same thing so
again it helps you understand
this right last but not the least
structures helped design drugs drug
design structures are integral to drug
design
that is what i do for a living this is
what i do i look at structures and
i do drug designing drug repurposing
that's actually part of my research
that's what i do for a living
so it's actually phenomenal how to come
up and i'm sure all of you have heard of
rem deceiver does it ring a bell
have you all heard of rem deceiver it's
all over the news these days
do you yes what where which context did
you hear about ram deceiver
covet correct so we heard about kobet
right so for kobe
exactly for covid they said oh my
goodness render silver actually works
and it actually does not cure them but
at least it minimizes
the hospitalization stay for some of the
patients how does rem decibel work how
did they find graham decimal
through structural biology they actually
docked renders he were to rna different
rna polymerase of this covid
and they said well you know that's how
they actually found that i'm just watch
so they're actually using it so there
are many drugs
that people are desperately trying to
find for kovit
including myself we are doing drug
repurposing how are we doing drug
repurposing we're just using all the
drugs that are already out there
and trying to dock it to all the
different proteins and figuring out
the way if it'll actually work and where
can we explain the mechanism right
now again these are some more examples
so
imani it's an imaniti nib it's a
tyrosine kinase inhibitor
anytime you see if at the end of any
drug
that means it is against a kinase right
so we have all of this
ab means antibodies so we have all of
these nomenclatures so humanitarian
again was actually the structure is
available and
it was you know imaginative binds to the
structure
and this is again it's a cholesterol
lowering drug atrostatin i'm sure you've
all heard of statins
and in fact i started as one of the
things that i put on my slide yesterday
when i was talking about
snips right so we have identified some
snips
that actually um you know some people it
why statins work in some people
it does not work in some people why does
it give adverse effects
uh side effects in some people so we
actually talked about this yesterday
right so again
three dimensional structures right this
is again listen no prell so this is
actually there are lots i'm just giving
you some examples
of how structures were actually used in
order to understand
the drugs how the drugs bind and how the
drugs interact with the proteins and all
of those fun stuff
i'm sure all of you have heard of
ibuprofen correct
this is something that uh people like me
who have headaches all the time
uh from different things actually take a
lot right ibuprofen
and it's a popular one right so again
it's for pain relieving and
inflammation uh relieving inflammation
so
you know this is how it is so at the end
of the day many proteins are used in
treatment of diseases
hormone erythropoietin and this is again
it's a hormone monoclonal
antibody so i said ab which is an
antibody monoclonal antibody
so this is an antibody molecule so that
actually binds
to its you know um
where is the pink that they're talking
about so this is the pink color here
they're talking about
so the antibody binds to its antigen
binding sites what are the amino acids
that are involved in this binding
all of these things so right so i think
i've given you enough examples
of how structures are actually used in
drug design
and i'm sure you've all heard of this as
well right a's
is two i'm sure you've all heard of a's
and a2 again this has been become very
popular right now because of cover again
is true this is not ace aces downstream
of a2 which is the receptor that curve
it binds to
right so these are all different
examples you know what and
last but not the least a picture is 1000
words right when you look at the picture
you know exactly where the ligand is
binding
this is again an antigen antibody
interaction
um so exactly without structures we
won't be able to understand exactly
where things bind
what kind of interactions that they
actually take and all of those things
right again so antigen antibody and the
way they work i'm sure you've all
learned
is by shape complementarity right
and induced fit so when an antigen binds
to an antibody that is actually true for
any ligand protein interaction they
actually the minute they bind they
induce some conformational changes
and so it's kind of a fit right
so now any questions up to this point
um any questions so
i have have i convinced you that
structures are actually
extremely important to understand
functions and they actually play a big
big role
in many different things yes good if
those of you there were like hmm
i'm not still convinced that structures
are helpful within the next few slides
i'm sure i'm going to convince you right
now we know that our life is not
maintained by
orphans right we are not alone right
even in the cell
the proteins don't work alone everything
is coordinated and it's just
amazing and fascinating how proteins
talk to each other and how they
you know i call this a relay system
right in olympics you have the four by
underdog relay system one has to give
the relay to the other one the other one
has to do
so pretty much it's all a network
systems network rights
it's all about networks in ourselves and
in our lives as well now so many social
networks networks there's nothing
that is we can do with our network so we
have organs
we have tissues tissues are made up of
cells
cells are made up of molecules and
molecules are made up of atoms
correct so now a cell is an organization
of millions
of molecules proper communication
between these molecules is actually
extremely essential to the normal
functioning of the cell
and to understand communication between
molecules
we have to understand the arrangement of
this particular
atoms um
okay so i am seeing a question here i
would like to know
um if you can actually post the question
to everyone i think that will be helpful
so that um if i'm not seeing the
question then at least be
sure someone else will actually
monitoring the chat will be so i'll be
able to answer
um so i would like to know if the
structure
complementarity can trigger a series of
wrong
pathway in terms of disease like any
example
so um i'm not sure if you're
i'm understanding your question
correctly but i'm gonna rephrase your
question the way i'm understanding it
and you tell me if that's what you're
trying
to ask so you're trying to say that
something that binds so for example
a drug um an antibody that's binding to
an
antigen in the cell right so it's
because of complementarity
you're asking whether this can trigger
wrong pathways does it mean that if
another protein exists with the same
shape and that whether this drug
because of the complementarity that this
makes this may have with other proteins
that look alike
whether that is actually going to cause
any adverse reactions in a disease is
that correct formula is that the
question you're asking
if that is a question are asking
absolutely correct
uh that that is what we we are
struggling with
because uh for example kinesis right
i mean the kinases um all the kinases
that belong to us very
same family will have similar structures
if they have similar structures um
they will have similar functions right
so which means a drug
for kinase a um
may bind to another chinese b that looks
like kinase a
right that's why we are having issues
with
uh cross reactivity we are having issues
with
side effects we are having issues with
non-specific
binding and that is actually a big
problem that we are actually having
and yes that's why you know that we are
actually figuring out how to make
something
specific specificity is actually
an issue right so we do have examples a
lot of drugs
for example tarzeiwa is an example that
comes to my mind
it's actually uh it's given for cancers
and
sava actually binds to a couple of
proteins
although it was actually i don't
remember i don't recall exactly what it
was developing which of the
um kinases or or which of the proteins
it was
developed against the specific target
but it does bind to egfr
it binds to several different proteins
so yes we could have issues
with with that it's a very good question
does that answer your question
okay so how do you create a specificity
for a drug
jeffrey that's an a that's a million
dollar question and in fact
i'm actually working on that very same
thing
how do you become specific right so the
specificity problem is actually
is a little complicated but yes we can
what we can do is we usually use if you
hold
on for a minute i'm going to explain
within the next coming slides
i think it'll be better if i actually
show you something and then i
will actually explain it's actually a
question that i'm actually working on so
hold on jeffrey i'm going to answer a
question in a minute
so now this is a molecular medicine
missionary and we are going to be doing
hands-on
of looking at protein data bank and so i
think that
we will talk about all of these things
when we actually do
uh you know uh protein dynamic hands-on
right in a cell what happens is it's all
molecular networks right so we actually
have
several different pathways millions of
different pathways so
what exactly happens in one pathway if
there is a problem does it affect a
pathway downstream
what do you all think actually it
actually does right so what happens here
actually affects what happens here as
well that's what again
um we call it systems medicine systems
biology it's all about a system as a
whole right
so we are all talking about all of those
things these are all the different
biochemical pathways and i'm sure
that you've all actually seen all of
these things and a few different popular
pathways that we all talk about
is glycogen degradation citric acid
cycle
pentose pathway path with all of these
different pathways why am i talking
about all of these pathways
i'm talking about all of these pathways
because at the end of the day
any pathway you take right this is the
example of a citric acid
cycle that's that's presented to you
this is a structural view of the citric
acid cycle
right so all the enzymes that are
involved in the citric acid cycle the
structures are known
right so why is that important so if
this structure
uh this structure is important this
particular enzyme is important
because the product of this particular
enzyme triggers
this one right and then the substrate
this becomes a substrate of this
and the product of this becomes a
substrate of the next step that's how
all these cycles work right
so there is a problem here then we
already know that there is going to be a
problem down here
a problem here is going to impact
problem here right so that's what
happens so
until we had all of these structures we
couldn't understand exactly why
it's not binding or it's binding too
tightly the products are not being
harmed
and maybe a hydrogen bond is lost
and all of those things right so looking
at everything in three dimensions
actually gives you a more insight into
the functionality all of all of these
things right
so that's where it comes to high the
solution structural biology
so using atomic structure to understand
how biomolecules communicate and
functions right so
what tools do we use i'm showing a lot
of pretty pictures to my eyes they all
look pretty right they're all pretty
pictures of helices and strands and all
of those things
that we're going to talk about so what
do you think are the tools that we
actually use
to make those pretty pictures
do you know any what and what techniques
are actually being used
that actually give you those pretty
three-dimensional structures
any any ideas what um methodologies are
used yes absolutely
um x-ray exactly x-rays are used x-ray
crystallography used nmr correct
and j-mole yes jeffrey j-mole is used
but j-mole is more of visualization
so gmo is used for looking at structures
but x-ray crystallography nuclear
magnetic resonance spectroscopy
and there is one other technique that is
being used that you guys have not
said anything else that you want to add
to the plate yes you write x-ray nmr
one more technique that is used
so this is x-ray crystallography this is
nuclear magnetic resonance
electron microscopy absolutely
cryo-electron microscopy
yes spectroscopy correct absolutely
correct
so um electron microscopy you know what
now even a lot of structures of covalent
are actually done by electron microscopy
the reason is electron each one
actually has uh you know pros and cons
of using these techniques but of course
x-ray crystallography remains as the
gold standard
of methodology and of course nmr as well
because i'm an x-ray i'm trained in
x-ray crystallography i think this is
the best but i'm just kidding
uh but a majority of the structures are
solved by extra crystallography we have
nuclear magnetic resonance and electron
microscopy
also now because we have lots of
information remember the big data we
talked about we have lots of information
enough to do modeling computation right
based on what we already have from all
of these different techniques
and okay and visualization and all of
those things so these are all the
different tools that we use
in structural biology right to solve the
structures
now this is the fun part yes what are
the benefits
of each of these techniques that is a
whole new lecture
jeffrey but i'm just going to quickly
tell you um x-ray crystallography all of
them actually
measure give you the atomic resolution
or the atomic positions
right at the atomic level they give you
the coordinates of every single atom in
your protein
now what are the advantages and
disadvantages
advantages of x-ray crystallography it
is actually
um it's a gold standard technique and it
can actually you can write
we were able to solve the whole
structure of a ribosome
using x-ray crystallography you can
imagine how huge a ribosome is right
so there is no limitation on the size
right
nmr has limitations on the size of the
protein that we actually can use
uh can measure using nmr spectroscopy
electron microscopy does not also have
size in fact it's better than extract
crystallography because you can actually
look at the whole cell
by electron microscopy but what is
different between electron microscopy
and x-ray crystallography is
the resolution of what you get out of
electron microscopy
is lower than what you get of x
regulators luxury but i
i must say that of course a
crystallography there is radiation
a damage and the biggest problem with
x-ray crystallography is you need
crystals
before you have to make proteins as
crystals and i can tell you having done
that
it can be a nightmare to crystallize a
protein not all proteins
can be crystallized so that is the
bottleneck in x-ray crystallography
so each one has its um advantages and
disadvantages
and each one is actually complementary
to the other
so nmr actually gives you hydrogen
information
uh because protons are the main center
to nuclear magnetic resonance
extra crystallography it's an electrons
because it's x-ray beam
so electrons are the ones that diffract
x-rays
but then again you can see hydrogens in
crystallography so we have to model it
right so um yes you have to purify the
protein and all of those things good
looks like you guys are very interested
in
uh the the methodology let me see if i
come up with some time to actually talk
to you more about these things right
yes so jeffrey did it answer your
questions little bit at least
right you get a big overall picture of
what the advantages and disadvantages of
each of those techniques
um yes okay yes overview good now
structure show and tell all this is my
favorite part
of what just i want all of you to
actually
um close your eyes for a second just
kidding right don't sleep off
i just want you to imagine a protein
sequence in front of your eyes
right and just a disciplined sequence
right in front of your eyes and now i
want you to tell
if you have a structure what can it
tell that your plain old sequence
primary sequence cannot
tell you what can structure tell you
that the sequence cannot tell you
just imagine a plain old sequence in
front of your eyes
right so what can structure tell you
that the sequence cannot tell you
just quickly i just want to see you guys
are really really interacting
smart so you're able to polarity um so
exactly so when you say kareena polarity
you mean about
a charge distribution uh if that is the
case
yes fitting of molecules absolutely that
is correct polarity of course charges
fitting of molecules absolutely uh eva
yes it is correct and superna yes
interaction absolutely correct
absolutely chandrani i i could say
pretty much you guys have filled my
slide
right you guys are amazing so it
actually tells you how
molecules are packed it tells you
interaction right
and i think that uh karina talked about
polarities in a way
i think if that's what you were
referring to it actually interaction
and then it actually tells you how a
folding how does they fold which means
which part of the molecule is close to
which part of the molecule right
just imagine right this helix and this
helix right
in a primary sequence say this is
residue number
30 to 35 and this is about 500 to
i'm just making up numbers from a
sequence you won't know
that regions 30 to 35 is actually
physically close in three-dimensional
space to 500 and 550 right
500 and 500 of amino acid 500 is far
away from amino acid 15 a primary
sequence would you all agree
but in three dimensions because of the
effect of folding they come so close to
each other
which we wouldn't know with just looking
at a primary sequence
and of course uh one of you actually
told me about introduction of different
more
different parts uh how does active sites
and binding sites at chandrani i think
yes
so how does a ligand actually bind to
and where does it buy
that are making the binding pocket what
are the
regions that are exposed to the solvent
what are the regions
excuse me and if you have two structures
that are very similar
you can just superimpose them to figure
out whether they're similar or not and i
think we're going to be doing this in
our hands-on session when we do
structures
we're going to be superimposing uh the
molecule of hemoglobin
and we're going to a normal hemoglobin
and a sickle the hemoglobin and we're
going to find the difference right
and then this is actually electrostatic
and shape
and um i think one of you actually asked
me about
how do you make i don't know if it was
jeffrey how do you make something
specific right
so this is how we look at it we actually
look at charge distribution
we actually look at hydrogen bond
interactions we actually look at all of
these different
interactions and we look at the energies
to figure out
how we can make something specific so we
may actually change one of the atoms
in the drug so that it changes its whole
um hydrophobicity and you know it's
polarity or i'm just
you know using those words that you guys
have used so we can actually
change the interaction between this
and i'm sure although the structures are
very similar between two things
we can actually make it very specific by
altering the
atoms in the drug to make it more basic
or more
acidic or adding more hydrogen bonds or
you know
are introducing a salt bridge or
something like that
right so that is pretty much how it's a
lot of work and a lot of things that go
in so i'm just giving you a simplistic
answer of how something can be
made specific and then
of course with a structure you will
understand what is a quaternary
structure right
or do all structures have a quaternary
structure do you think
do all proteins have a quaternary
structure
what is your answer
no of course you're correct um why
why don't all proteins actually have a
quaternary structure
so that becomes definition you're all
correct yes all proteins do not have
quaternary structures
only those proteins that come together
from two different polypeptide chains
which means those two polypeptide chains
actually code for two different genes
right so when two different things come
together
um and quaternary structure is
made or proteins that contain two
different polypeptide chains coming from
two different genes
those are the proteins that actually
have a quaternary structure and
immediately you guys can give me an
example of a protein that you all know
we've been talking about quite a bit in
the last two days is
um something that actually has a
coordinated structure
uh any guesses of a protein kinases i
am not sure about that but another
protein that i actually mentioned that
they're going to be
that causes sickle cell anemia
hemoglobin actually actually yes
hemoglobin actually has a coordinated
structure so we'll look at that
then some one of you actually said that
we actually can do active sites and
functional motives yes
we actually can get active sites based
on a three-dimensional structure
okay so now structure show and show and
tell
that now you understand what structures
can actually tell you
that you cannot get this information
from just looking at a string
just a sequence along right what are the
key players in this game
proteins proteins play a very key role
in our living system right
they help in catalysis enzymes they
actually help in transport there are
transport proteins
they are information transfer proteins
we have hormones
so the whole protein world can be
actually divided into
each one is given a job in the cell to
do
and if they fail to do the job that
they're given
that's when something goes wrong when
something goes wrong
we and that manifests itself in you know
a disease of
for example right so everything has to
be organized in the cell everything has
to wake up at a certain time
and has to let go a certain time if they
actually don't do
then that's a problem right so things
happen at
very femtoseconds inside the cell so
things have to go on and off on and off
it's really funny fun to watch things in
in real life under a microscope right
so these are all different examples of
classes of different proteins we have
structural
proteins contractiles and all of those
things right you all know these are all
different examples
each one does a unique job and some
proteins you know multitask
they are given more roles to play so
which means they are very very busy
right some of us have lots of hats to
wear right so
some major categories regulatory
proteins they control gene expression
receptor proteins they bind to things
you have structural proteins some of
them
they just have to you know fold in a
certain form or a way to actually
understand the functions of these things
transfer proteins are proteins that
transfer something from one thing to
another
do you already all know an example of a
trans protein something that transfers
something
from one to another we have a lot of
different transfers
transfer or transfer races in our
systems
immunoproteins these are very very
important
proteins because they're they are the
ones that are pretending
protecting from foreign agents right so
your immune system is very very
important
right and then many more right i'm not
doing justice to everything
this is just some examples right this is
the world so world of wars and functions
there are lots and different
each protein folds differently and
they because fold is very closely
related to its function
so each protein folds differently based
on the
work it's given and do you think we have
a finite number of holes in this world
or you have you think that we have
infinite number of
fools or proteins the other way to ask
uh membrane transfer proteins yes
jeffrey that's correct
now do you think that proteins can fold
in any way that they actually
want to fold in other words
do we have an infinite number yeah
microtubule bond proteins correct
so do you think we have an infinite
number of holes in this
spray in this that proteins can have
that we the number of total folds we
have
can be a million for example now why yes
that is correct
yes yes we do have a finite
number of holes yes due to static
infection that's right we have
we have um very finite number of holes
do we know exactly what that number is
we still don't
know the exact number but you know there
are num
that are numbers floating in the you
know literature like 10 000 poles and
all of that but my guess is that we're
almost reaching the number of holes that
we actually can see
why because every structure that's
coming out new structure is actually
looking like something we already know
right
so the reason we have only finite number
of holes is because
the beauty is they all have to obey
geometry
you cannot have any angle any distance
anything that you want you know what at
the end of the day every protein has to
follow the
law of physics so that's probably you
know physics is very important and
you know everything is follows rules now
um do you all know that we have 21 amino
acids
um so why am i bringing this up i'm sure
you all know your amino acids correct
the reason we're all i'm bringing this
up is each amino acid
actually has an important role to play
in a protein
structure in a in an each because
each of them actually you know have a
different physiochemical property
so when they fold together some of them
coordinate and work well together
and others actually don't so they group
together
so that they actually work well within
the context
of a fold right so each protein has a
unique structure
right and this is the amino acid
sequence
and you fold this this is what you get
right so depending on where the amino
acids are
the they actually take sides where they
want to be
right so i'm sure that you know
hydrophobic amino acids hydrophilic
amino acids
amphipathic amino acids i just thought
you all
know all of that and so i'm not actually
going to be going over that just to tell
you that hydrophobic means phobia means
fear of something right
these proteins actually are scared of
water so most of the hydrophobic
proteins are actually formed in the
inner core
they actually are stay away from water
hydrophilic means these are amino acids
that actually are like water so they can
interact well with water so these are
the
amino acids that are actually formed on
the surface of the protein
and then anthopathic means that these
are amino acids that actually kind of
have both
properties of hydrophobic idophobic and
hydrophilic
right so proteins actually are very very
organized
they are organized into primary
structure
secondary structure tertiary structure
and quaternary structures right and then
protein structure has a hierarchical
organization
so what is a primary structure do all
proteins have a primary structure
what do you think does all proteins have
to have a primary structure
of course yes right this is a no-brainer
because we all start with the protein
sequence right so everything has a
sequence
and that tells you the arrangement of
every single amino acids right
so does every protein have a secondary
structure
yes of course does every protein have a
tertiary structure yes of course because
the tertiary structure is the one
that gives the fold of the protein and
that tells you how they interact with
each other does every structure have a
quaternary every protein have a
quaternary structure
we already discussed that no every
protein does not have a quaternary
structure right so
the important things are the tertiary
structures
right how they interact now i already
told you right the sequence
determines the three-dimensional
structure so everything that you want to
know about the protein structures
already the secret is already there in
the primary
structure right and but the only problem
is we are still facing a problem where
we still don't know exactly how to
get that information from abenitio
using physics first principles right
and the next person who is going to
solve this
protein folding problem is where you
have a sequence and you just fold it you
find a way to fold it from first
principles
is the next nobel prize winning person
in the field of structural biology and i
kind of have guesses of who that would
be because i'm seeing a lot of work from
that group
um but that is where we're all waiting
for where you'll be able to hold a
protein sequence you just take a
sequence
and you give it to a machine and it's
going to come up with all that but of
course some of us will be out of a job
after that
right because we're doing
crystallography and nmr and all of those
things but
you know first principles but that's
going to take some time because we're
still trying to understand these
proteins
now certain positions how does a protein
know
how to start holding what is the
position of the amino acid that
starts folding so we have a lot of
theories and hypothesis around this
certain positions along the chain of the
protein sequence actually act as a
nucleation points
and chaperones right it's a type of a
helper protein
and we know we have a lot of chaperone
proteins that we have identified
and these are all the different proteins
that actually help
in um assisting uh protein folding
right they all have um something that
they assist in protein folding
now this is the primary structure right
this is just a structure and every
protein as you all know
has an n-terminus amino terminus and a
carboxy terminus
we always read the protein from the
n-terminus to the c-terminus
right that is our thing and this is how
it folds right so this is a primary
structure
and the only thing that we actually
could understand based on the primary
structure is we
actually may be able to say okay this
protein
could we have a disulfide branch maybe
forming a disulfide bond
but if there are 10 or 20 different
cysteines we don't know which cysteine
is going to pair with with cysteine
and if the wrong cysteine pairs with the
you know iron
there's a wrong pairing of these
cysteines what happens
you'll get a misfolded protein right the
protein folding is very very important
now i'm going to discuss
uh the different components so you have
basic
secondary structural units of the
protein so you actually have
this is the how the protein within you
have hydrogen bonds right hydrogen bonds
are most important bonds
that actually stabilize a protein
structure
they actually stabilize the even water
molecule right you have lots of hydrogen
bonds hydrogen bonds are actually very
important bonds
right i give a whole lecture believe me
or not on hydrogen ones right
now secondary structures is we have
three different secondary structures
right so you have a helix then you have
a strand
right and then you have what is called a
loop
right that connects the different
secondary structural elements
no protein can exist without
which of these three secondary
structural elements you think that
proteins cannot exist without
you know there are proteins that can
just be helices yes correct that's
correct look
loop is the one because that is a
connectivity so every single protein
structure
will actually have loads but protein
there are protein structures which may
or which may contain only helices or
there are protein structures that
actually contain only beta strands
but there is no structure of course
there are no structures that have only
loops because then
there's nothing we can you know they can
do
right because they're just random right
so they don't have a shape or form they
they're so flexible so so these are the
three
and can you believe the whole world of
holes is just made up of only three
things so life is actually
simple when you look at it but then it's
still complex but
there is infinite number of ways that
they can combine
right these structural secondary
structural elements can combine
in a protein to actually give you
different folds right isn't that
fascinating it's just fascinating to me
right
so this is a strand this is a helix so
in a helix
you have hydrogen bonds in consecutive
amino acids within the helix
in a strand these are different parts of
the protein so the
hydrogen bonds are between two different
strands
right many different strands together
actually form a sheet right beta sheet
right
now these are the secondary this is
alpha helix this is actually a picture
sheet
right so now and that's a shape now
secondary structures
so they associate these are the three
different things and of course the loops
are actually called referred to as
uh what do the colors represent you mean
here i
in the colors don't mean anything i just
colored them differently
so that you can see them distinctively
so at this
in this particular there is colors
doesn't but in this representation
usually
blue is for nitrogens or other
hydrophobic and reds
are actually oxygens right
so in this particular representation we
usually use
blue and reds for uh positive and
negative
um i mean you know positive and negative
charge distributions we usually
typically use blue and red
but in this particular case this
actually doesn't mean
anything in terms of colors red is my
favorite color
that's all it needs in this particular
case right so now
they associate with different patterns
of hydrogen bonds right all of them
and sometimes loops are actually called
the turns
and um you know random coil
so loops are called different things
right and there are
lots and believe me or not there are
lots and lots of different turns in a
protein structure
and again i do a whole lecture on that
twists and turns and protein structures
right there are lots of different types
of tests
now this is the tertiary structure in
which where how
these secondary structural elements
combine to form a three-dimensional
structure
and tertiary and arrangement right in
three dimensions
right so these are all in three
dimensions they all form together and
how they interact with each other so
that is what tertiary structure means
these are all the different tertiary
structures of proteins
and i must also tell you in structural
biology
it's almost like talking a new language
right how
you present your protein structure
actually talks a lot
for example this one is called a sp
these are all spheres right
so this is a representation of a protein
structure right you're just representing
it with spheres
then this just tells you a overall shape
it gives you the overall charge
distribution uh
surface representation of the protein
but here
this is all bonds right this is actually
going to give you
a wired representation that tells you
every single amino acid is given
to you and so this is a representation
that you would actually use
for maybe showing how one amino acid
residue interacts with another amino
acid residue
this one is the overall tertiary
structure how the strands and where the
positions of the strands are
and where the helices are so in
structural biology we use different
representation to represent different
things right to
convey different things to you now this
is a surface representation
that that says blue is electrostatically
positive
and the red is electrostatically
negative
so this is a very important
representation that i use a lot
to understand where are drug binds where
are the different
you know there are binding pockets you
can see deep down pockets
and if it is red i should be looking for
a drug
that is complementary to red right
because like poles ripple
and so we have complementarity so this
is what tells me if i have to bind a
drug here if this is a pocket
then i have to find a drug that is
actually more basic correct so
so that there is charge attraction
between them right so that's what we use
all of this for
now quaternary structure is between
different chains
and uh and also you know what um
this tells you how two different
polypeptide chains actually coming from
two different genes
actually come together and they form all
of these different domains
and we used to call them subunits
um and i stay away from using that term
because it means different things
subunits here there are two different
polypeptides
here in this particular case is a
tetramere this is another protein so
there are lots of proteins
that actually have a quaternary
structure right there's a whole list of
them
and these are all different examples of
quaternary structures comes together
in a protein and functions the majority
of all the complex reactions in your
body in the cell
are all coming from different proteins
coming together
to do that particular function right
okay so the reasons of secondary
structure formation
is the side chains hydrophobic
residues are always in in located in the
hydrophobic core
and the main chain atoms of the same
residues in most cases are also
within the hydrophobic core right
hydrophobic
is actually very important interaction
right because
uh of that forms the core of every
protein structure
since the presence of the polar groups
in the hydrophobic environment is very
very
unfavorable to the main chain atoms and
it's also neutralized by hydrogen bonds
so most of the cytophyllic acid residues
actually
are inside form the core of the protein
the two most efficient ways of hydrogen
form formation is to bring alpha helix
or a beta sheet
and did you all know that linux falling
or was the one who actually discovered
uh asthma helix right alliance police
actually came up and
actually discovered a half alpha helix
right this is so-called space filling
model of
alpha helix and um and i don't
know and he is the one that actually won
two nobel prizes
right and i am told uh
by actually i heard the story from
someone who actually worked with linus
pauling
uh david davies uh who unfortunately
passed away
uh who was actually the first person um
and i actually had the honor of meeting
him
and working with him actually and he
told me the story about how linus
pauling came up with alpha helix and i
love to share the story with my students
he apparently had the flu
and he was just playing around with the
piece of paper and he was folding it and
all of those things and boom
he came up i am not sure i actually
initially thought it was a fairy tale
but apparently it's actually real what
you can actually do
uh when you actually have fever right so
for me i just go around and sleep right
so but that was the story behind linus
paul
right it's an interesting so the
properties of various
secondary structures this is all alpha
this is alpha helix
so as i i told you right these hydrogen
bonds
are internal and these these are the
hydrogen one that stabilize
alpha helix right and um
oops and so it goes
from n-terminus to c-terminus right
alpha helix
right and now these are the ones that
stabilize our alpha helix
right and what happens if there is a
mutation
within an alpha helix right say that
this amino acid is actually mutated
and it is maybe a glycine
right so say that this is mutated
because of the charge distribution of
alpha helix there is a there is a dipole
moment
at the end of the alpha helix right that
is what i want you to
remember right now we'll come back to
this discussion of why
what will happen if there is a mutation
here right
now there are two different types of
alpha helices right
um one is a left-handed alpha-helices
and one is a right-handed alpha helix
and again you have to remember when it
comes to structures they all have to
obey the rules of physics
they have to obey laws so you cannot
have anything in everything because
they're not
energetically favorable so which of
these helices do you think is most
commonly
found in protein structures one of this
is actually not found
the other it's very excuse me it's very
rarely found
so which one do you think it's actually
found is it a left-handed helix or a
right-handed
yes absolutely actually it is a
right-handed helix that is actually
formed
the left-handed helix is actually
energetically not favorable
now does it mean that it's completely
not even
there but we do see occasionally
because there are always exceptions to
the rule but
it's still rare right now these are all
the different hydrogen bonding patterns
so i said there is actually
a charge at the end of every helix
there is a net charge because of the
carboxy
amino terminus which is a positively
charged nitrogen atoms right
nh3 and here is coh
so every helix hence ends with the amino
terminus
and the carboxy terminals so they
actually have a dipole moment
and they actually have a charge and
these distances
are always the same right so they all
have to obey laws
and rules now this is another
representation which is called the
seepage
space filling model of a helper helix
right
now there are periodic patterns
uh that are observed so there are
proteins that actually follow patterns
right
patterns is very important in life right
so if you identify a pattern we could be
uncovering something about that
particular protein right
so these are all the different domains
right so these are all the patterns so
you have
all of these um you have a strand
you have a you know helix a helix strand
helix strand helix i'm sorry it's helix
strand
you know helix strength so there is
actually a pattern right there is a
strand there is a helix as a strand
there is a helix is a strand
ah there's a helix right so there is a
pattern some of these patterns actually
help
and if we identify these patterns we can
actually understand the functions of
these proteins
right have you all had a heard of
patterns and proteins
a helix turn helix motif and these are
all called structural motifs in a
protein
right have you all heard of uh patterns
yes and there is a pattern so have you
all heard of helix turn
helix and do you know what
that is actually known for a helix stern
helix pattern is known for what do you
know
uh any things that it is actually known
to bind to something
um any guesses of what a helix turn
helix motif in a protein structure
actually binds to an example
that comes to your mind helixton helix
is known for binding dna
so how does it help you if you find a
helixtone helix motif in a protein
structure
immediately you can say ah this could be
binding dna
right that's how we understand functions
right the most
common location of an alpha helix is
alongside of the protein with one side
of this so you will find lots of these
alpha helices
on the surface of the protein and
immediately what does it tell you about
the amino acids that actually form a
helix
i'm telling you that it is facing
outside
and the hydrophobic core of the helix
will be facing inside
which means all the amino acids that
actually are charged like aspartic acid
glutamic acid
lysine arginine that actually have a
charge will be facing the outside
because they can interact with water and
all the violin
alanine uh all of those will be facing
the inside of the protein
right so this will actually result in a
periodic pattern of all of these things
and um i told you right there are lots
of fists and turns
there are also lots of other types of
illnesses and i think that's
i don't want to confuse you and i don't
want to put you all to sleep
right now by talking about lots of
things and you know overwhelming you
but i just want you to know that when
you're reading a paper for example when
you're doing your research and you
read a structured paper you may actually
encounter
a helix that's called 310. it just means
three amino acids
within a turn so it's a very short
stretch of helix
and then you also see a pie helix so
each one has a different definition but
these are all
uh you know uh are all examples and uh
yes it is very likely i'm not sure it's
actually a polyalanine i think
it's a polyalamine right um and so these
are all
however for a number of reasons all of
these heli are alpha helices right
and so these are all the different types
of helices what is the difference
between how do you define something is
an alpha helix or a 310 helix or a pi
helix
it all depends on the hydrogen bonding
pattern
and the number of amino acids that
actually form them i don't want to
confuse you
any more right just to say that now the
next secondary structure elements is
trans and i told you that strands or
you know what you have hydrogen bonds
between different parts of the molecule
right
so you have anti-parallel strands
this is the anti-parallel strand so this
is the n-terminus which means this is
amino acid 1
amino acid 2 amino acid 3 4
5 6 and this is 7 8
9 10 right so this is a turn right and
the hydrogen bonding is between
amino acid here and amino acid here i
forgot the number that i was counting
right
so this is the anti-parallel strand now
the parallel strand
so this is the anterior and that this is
the hydrogen bonding in an anti-parallel
strand right now in a parallel strand
so you have one uh which is the thing
so this is you have one two three four
five
six this is amino acid seven eight nine
ten so they just paddle
and you can see that the hydrogen bond
is distorted right
which one do you think is more commonly
found in protein structures
is it parallel strand or anti-parallel
style just by based on what i just
showed you
because it's all at the end of the day
it has to be stable so which one is
more common that is correct
anti-parallel strand is more common
can any one of you tell me why
anti-parallel strand is more common than
a parallel strand
any guesses of why antiparallel strand
is more common
uh ants might have loops that's correct
but uh less steric hindrance
yes so uh
antiparallel correct um any other
reasons
so i'm just going to tell you right so
this one right this is anti-parallel
and so it goes in this direction and
then there is a short loop here
right and then it goes in this direction
right interaction uh between n and c
that is absolutely correct so you know
what so this turns here right so it's a
short loop
and there's just a couple of amino acids
one amino acid that connects
to here that goes here right now in a
parallel stand what happens is
this actually has to come all the way
here
which is practically impossible right
it's practically impossible
for one amino acid to be able to connect
to something that's so
far away so it's energetically not
possible
it's practically not even possible so it
doesn't exist
okay does it make sense and
this is a parallel stand and also all
these are destructive so
parallel strands that form a shoot
actually are not found in protein
structures
right because they don't they the energy
because of energetics and because of the
way that these things actually form
now now that i've told you about strands
and i've told you about helices now i
asked you a question if you remember a
few slides before
and i'm going to make a statement and i
want you to think about it
a mutation in a helix is extremely very
very expensive compared to a mutation in
a strand
right what do i mean by expensive what
do i mean is that
the effect of one mutation in a helix
is really going to disrupt the protein
structure
far more than a mutation in a strand
now that you've looked at both the helix
and the strand can you tell me
why that would be the case that a
mutation in a helix is
going to disrupt lot more than a
mutation
in in a strand think about it i know you
all know the answers
um it's actually simple
based on just all that i've said any
guesses
why a mutation in a helix um
is going to be you know not that
tolerable
any guesses are you all tired looks like
you're a little bit tired
i know it's a lot but um we'll hopefully
get through
um might affect interaction of protein
with surrounding molecules
um just think about just within the
helix itself what happens
alpha helix is at the surface maybe
sheath some more deeper dipole yes
marissa you got the point yes all
uh perimila and superna what you have
said is is correct in a different
context but mary said that's correct
absolutely correct it's because of the
dipole moment right i told talk to you
about that
when you have a dipole moment there is a
charge distribution so what happens is
when you have a single mutation in a
helix right
so what happens is um
what happens is a mutation here actually
is going to be disrupting the hydrogen
bond
where is that this is better say that
there's a mutation here
and it's going to be disrupting the
hydrogen bonding pattern of this
but what happens is because of that all
the whole
effect of this is going to be felt by
the entire helix
and the surrounding that it interacts
with so it's going to be disrupting the
entire thing but then the same reason is
why
is that not the case with a strand
it is not the case with the strand is
because you know what if there is a
mutation here
this hydrogen bond is not going to
happen but it's
actually going to be compensated by the
regions because it's linear
right so that is why a mutation in a
helix is far more
uh more it it is actually not tolerated
because it causes more damage to the
protein structure
right a lot of these
strands together as forms a sheet right
this is an
antiparallel sheet that i told you that
is actually found in protein structures
and this is the parallel as i can tell
you like this whole thing is not even
possible right
from here it has to get all the way here
and it's energetically not possible it
is not
physically possible for a bond to be
that big to connect to here
okay now is it clear about all of these
secondary structural elements
um and sometimes there are twists in a
beta sheet
a beta sheet can be twisted um and we
find those things as well
right almost all beta sheets actually
have twists right so that
it feels really nice to look at them the
twist is always right-handed
okay so now any questions i'm going to
pause for a moment because i know that i
threw a lot at you
in the last 10-15 minutes and i know
you're all getting tired
maybe i don't know depending on where
you are sleepy or
hungry um so are all hydrogen bonds in a
sheet in the same plane or in a helix
they are in a different okay that is
actually a fantastic question
this um can you explain the dipole
moment again okay sure i can
explain the dipole moment here again so
what i'm going to do
is get back to that slide um and i'm
going to answer that question as well
as superna about your question so what a
dipole moment
is is actually the helix goes this way
right so this would be one two how many
other residues that there are right
now what happens is there is a charge
at this end because this is the amino
terminus of the helix
this is the carboxy terminus of the
helix uh
where is that so here right so because
there is on this top of this plane there
is actually a charge distribution
along this helical plane so there is
actually a
net negative charge at the end of the
c-terminus because
carboxy right c-o-o is negative
nh3 is positive so here this is the
amino term so there is a net
positive charge at this end and there is
a net negative charge
so there is a charge distribution i go
across the
plane of this across the dipole moment
that's what we call that is actually
along the axis of the cellics that
causes the dipole moment
right because of the charge distribution
does that answer your question jeffrey
and
i'm going to answer uh how do you read
the 3d is there a step by step you read
a 3d struct
structure from interminus to 3 dominance
pretty much that's all we need now um
we'll need annotation of helix kindly
hover around it
uh what is i didn't understand that
question
and also superna did i answer your
question a peptide bond is always planar
period
peptide bond has to be planar so the
peptide bond
are always those atoms the atoms that
are in the peptide bond are actually
planar right so that probably hopefully
answered your question super now
number you i don't know what i am what
will need annotation of helix
uh can you um
point on what constitute helix oh i see
okay
what cons this is the helix
this whole thing is a helix right
this whole thing is a steroid cares
right so this
whole thing is one it's a helix and in a
folded structure this is the helix
okay is that does that i'm here are you
able to see my pointer
uh my and my mouse
yes okay good okay so did i answer all
of your questions if not we can i can
come back to it once we
finish the lecture um and then we can
have a discussion
right about everything so now
turns are the last part you know we have
lots and lots of twists
twist and stuns there are many different
types of turns
so you have a gamma turn and all of them
are i'm not going to
like you know literally confuse you but
all i want to
impress upon you from this is that there
are lots of different types of turns and
each of these different turns has
different functions
and how do you know something is a gamma
turn it is defined
by the number of amino acids that form
that turn and
also the hydrogen bonding heart pattern
that forms the turn
and so gamma turn beta turns alpha turns
these are all the different types of
turns that we find in protein structures
and there are many many people who
actually just focus their entire life on
looking at these terms
right now which turn is the most
commonly found
in protein structures have you heard
about any one of these terms
either when you're reading a you know in
your you know any of those things
so yes correct beta turn is the most
commonly found turns
right and then we have the gamma turn
and then everything else
now beta turns again it is defined by
the number of amino acids here
and what constitutes the hydrogen
bonding pattern in these things
right so it is all depends on
hydrogen bonds which amino acid residue
actually forms hydrogen bond with them
with amino acid if i is the first amino
acid
you have four amino acid i plus one i
plus two i plus c
and then you have actually i and i plus
three distance so you just it just
follows some rules
and it also follows phi and psi um
have you all heard of phi and psi um
dihedral two dihedral angles that are
integral to every single
protein structure um and there is a plot
that we plot
and um you know i think unfortunately i
may have taken off those slides just for
um not getting too deep uh and
you know drowning into this uh world of
structures and technology technical
details
um but do you have you all heard of
ramachandran plot
yes no no okay
so ramachandran plot okay you've all not
heard of ramachandran yes
okay so now you know what i think it's
actually will that be explained yes
actually you know what i am going to i
took away the slides
explaining ramachandran plot but you
know what when we are doing the hands-on
session um i believe on thursday on
protein structures i am going to explain
to you ramachandran plot because i think
it's important i
think i took away all of those slides to
explain ramadan and plot
but i promise that i'll explain to you
because when you actually are looking at
structures and doing hands-on
i think it will be more um you know
clear
for you what it actually means so i
definitely and several of you have
actually heard of ramachandran plot
it's actually a plot of insight that
tells you what is allowed
what is not allowed um in terms of
protein
folds um and all of those things but i'm
going to come back to that okay
now in terms of turns there are two
types of turns type one turn and type to
done
oh wow i didn't realize i had a effect
in this i must have done it in the
middle of the night um
wow that is nice i didn't think that
there was the sound effect but it's nice
so these are the hydrogen bonds
uh that is different between the two
types of terms in fact if we have time
today after if i finish everything i'm
planning to talk to you today then we
can i can explain ramachandran plot
today okay
so this is actually in the front and
this actually behind so you don't need
you're not going to have an exam
in this course and all that so but this
is just for your information
uh if you want to visit this later on
that there are different types of terms
type 1 and type 2
what is the difference so only specific
amino acid residues
are actually allowed to be in that turn
why do you think glycine is the only
possible amino acid at position 3 in a
type 2 10 what is so unique about
glycine
that it is the this is the glycine that
is
winning the price to be in that
particular position it's becoming
important
so why is what is what do you know about
glycine
um any any information
hydrogen is a as exactly a site chain
other than that
what do you know about glycine in terms
of
its flexibility and why is glycine
always found and known to be the most
flexible amino acids
uh hydrogen has a situation that is
correct and can you expand on that
superna
it is actually correct hydrogen io what
else do you all know about property of
alpha glycine amino acid
anything else that comes to your mind
about glycine
so glycine is one of the smallest amino
acids right so it can fit anywhere
sometimes
you know uh no steric energy it's very
small because that's correct it's
actually very very small
um it's always found in you know most of
the time glycine is found in a loop
because it's so flexible it's so small
so it can fit in many different things
right and yeah because it's small it
doesn't
uh cause anything oops i didn't now that
that was coming
right um
okay i didn't know sorry about that i
didn't realize that i didn't have these
side effects there may be more coming so
this is a type 1 term
and this is a type 2 term right the
hydrogen bonding pattern
is different and the amino acid that
this term forms actually is actually
very different
right now there are gamma terms just
quickly
it's again another turn there are
different types of gamma turns
um and again the difference between
gamma tones and beta terms is just that
the hydrogen bonds and amino acids that
are involved in these terms are actually
different
right other than that i don't want to um
confuse you anymore and
i want to mention beta bulges because
beta bulges is actually
amino acid that actually there are two
strands and you just
the amino acid just bulges out right so
you actually see why is bulges very
important bulges are actually very very
important for protein
function many of the antibodies
actually have bulges right they also
have bulges
antibodies actually have bulges right
and so bulges is actually important for
functions
right other than that and the other one
last thing i want to talk about
is proline is uh not found in
alpha helicis proline is actually called
a helix breaker
it actually breaks the helix
it's found in turns and why do you think
that proline has taken the name and
given the name of a helix
breaker why do you think it's called a
helix breaker
we don't want to see a proline in a
helix
and whether you know whether we like it
or not it is still
some proteins have that uh okay so can i
go back to bulges yes
do you have a question about bulges from
varimala
yes okay so bulges are something that
where one amino acid
is it's not remember see that this is
actually
um bulges are the ones that actually
literally bulge out
of a secondary structure right when you
look at this can you see that this is
bulged
this strand is actually bulged a little
bit right because of this amino acids
most of these amino acids are actually
big amino acids most of these bulges are
caused by tryptophans and so it bulges
out of from the
normal secondary structure
does that make does it clear your
question formula
and it is also very important for
structure prediction
and functions right so now
why is up helix uh why is a proline
called a helix breaker
what is unique about a proline amino
acid
that it is actually called a proline um
it is an e amino acid that is correct it
is an amino acid but other than that
imagine its
its structure right so the side chain of
the proline
folds back to the main chain and so it
actually causes a kink
right it's not like other amino acids
where they're actually
away from the main chain atom right from
the main chains
this is the peptide bond right co nh
right
so it is actually the proline amino acid
turns back and connects back to the main
chain
right so it comes back to the main chain
so that's why it causes a kink
and when you see a kink in a helix right
um it is
breaks the continuity of the helix it
breaks the continuity of the head legs
it actually also you know um and all of
those things
okay so now that is
it for all of the you know information
about all of those things which still
are major challenges in the field of
structural biology
and i want all of you young minds to
actually
look into this and you can actually come
up with solutions to some of these
problems
um yes in a sense
it actually um actually affects it
right um and the type of the question is
how does the proline amino acid actually
influence the dipole moment
um so it doesn't actually alter the net
charge
that you would have because uh but it
does alter
the polarity of its neighboring amino
acids so it affects the hydrogen bonding
pattern for
it to hydrogen bond with then
consecutive helix helix interactions it
probably attacks
affects the helix helix interactions
right
now how does the sequence determine the
three-dimensional how does a
three-dimensional structure relate to
its function
what is function right so this is a
question that i again
ask everyone because i keep telling you
we are where the whole important goal of
mission of all the scientists in the
world is to get
understand functions right but what is
function
what is what defines function right what
is function to you all
you're sitting through this lecture
right and i've been talking to you about
structure and function and function and
structure and what is function
how do you define function everything in
life has a function right function to
play we all have functions to play
so what is the function uh of a protein
what does it actually mean
anyone
i am sure that you all know the answer
to what a function is how do you define
functions
the world cup protein does that's
correct
it's intended role um that's correct
what does
it what it does for the cell fantastic
um all great things right so
biomolecular activities correct what
does it do
so all of each one of you have actually
defined function
right so what does it do what does the
protein do
and what are the important thing protein
sequence
structure and structure to function
right so that's pretty much what it is
so i'm telling you structure it helps
understand functions right the mr in
the enormous variety of protein
functions right
is based on their high specificity for
the molecules that they interact with
right
it can be interacting and these are
interaction
interacting partners i called as ligands
right a protein interacts with another
protein
in this case it's a protein like a
protein interacts with the dna
that is a dna is a ligand a protein
interacts with a small molecule
like majority of the proteins in the
cell actually bind to
small ligands like atp gtp
gmp and all of those things right which
you've all heard of these are all called
ligands a protein's function actually
it's defined by what it actually does
right
some proteins cleave some some majority
of the proteins are actually
enzymes which means they do uh you know
it's a catalytic function that they have
they cleave something
they transfer something they actually
reduce something oxidoreductases or they
actually you know
uh each one has different functions
right enzymes but not all proteins are
inside
right um and also those things right so
it all depends
but do you think they say that a protein
actually has
1000 amino acid residues
and do you think that all the thousands
amino acid residues are actually
important
for that protein to carry out its
function
right this is always puzzled to me right
in nature
we have like enzymes right say that an
enzyme is like thousand amino acid
residues right
but is thousand amino acid involved in
its catalytic activity of
actually cleaving something and doing
this electrostatic electrophilic attack
or electro
static attack or not no actually then
what is the role of the whole thing
so how can you break the thousand amino
acids into smaller bets
right so you're right right so all the
thousand amino acids are not important
for that enzyme it's only one or two
amino acids which we call the catalytic
amino acids right
histidines aspartic acid glycolytic
triad maybe there are three amino acids
that are important
but then what are they what is the
function of rest of the other amino
acids in that
so each amino acid or each part of this
is actually has a function right
so that is again a function right so you
can break up
these big proteins into smaller bits
and how can you break a big i mean a
protein into smaller bits what are those
called
you can break a protein into um
well yes at the end of the day it is all
you know points down to each amino acid
is from a quorum
that's correct so far now so we actually
break the whole protein into domains
right domains are the functional units
of a protein
right e the protein can have 10
different domains a protein can have
just one domain a protein can have like
you know two domains
you know all of those things at the end
of the day it's all about domains
but you can you break down the domains
into smaller bits
can you break down a domain yes motifs
correct you can break down the domain
into motifs correct
right so so hence protein ligand
interactions are central to molecular
recognition so
anything and everything it's all about
interactions right
so hence it is no surprise that the
biological function of a protein
are so connected to its
three-dimensional structure
and even a little damage to these
structures
is often a reason for loss of dramatic
effect that it has majority of
proteins one single mutation and we
talked about
uh meagan yes subunits that's correct
so you can put you can talk about um a
thousand amino acid residues
we can break that up into domains
then the domains we can break them into
different subunits within the protein
then we can break each one of them into
motifs
then and then of course you know jeffrey
we can get back to the codon level at
the end of the day if we keep breaking
them into smaller smaller bits
finally we'll figure out which amino
acid is coded by which one at the end of
the day
we can come down to all of those
different levels
right so even a little damage to these
structures often the reason for loss of
dramatic right so
we discussed a lot about monogenic
diseases where one single mutation is
actually causing a lot of damage
to the protein protein sequence
ah then it's actually a base phase we
can start with the codon base
change in the codon and either a base
pair and then that codes for a different
protein because of the mutation and
variation and then because it is
structured to function right one
mutation affects it right so
that is where so again this is uh this
is what we talked about yesterday
correct so we have diseases
we have inheritance and we have all of
these genes that are possible right so
all of these things single mutations
right now we're going to talk about
sickle cell anemia
right so sickle cell anemia is do you
know what makes the color of your blood
right
what what protein is involved in
uh making the color of your
heme yes correct all of you are very
correct right so
hemoglobin hemoglobin is the one that
makes the color
red and what else makes it red
so i'm sure you've all seen um all of
your veins right
and i have you all i'm sure i'm of
course iron that's correct iron in that
absolutely correct iron in that uh but
what happens to this right i'm not sure
of cause you're all too young and i
you know but i'm pretty sure that we
have gone to a doctor's office
and maybe you've had a blood drawn right
at some points in your life maybe you've
had blood tests
just to check everything is okay
oxygenate right that's absolutely
correct
so i'm sure that all of you have gone to
a doctor's office
and um they draw your blood correct in a
little tube
and have you all noticed what happens to
the blood in the little tube as they are
collecting the blood
is it always right or what happens to
that
have you all noticed um blood when they
start
doing a blood draw on you and they
actually have a tube
and um yes a dark arena correct it
darkens right it is
i would say it's more purple blue
correct
so you've all seen that and even your
veins right when you look at your hands
you see a lot of this bluish thing right
greenish thing
right it changes that's because you know
what it's there's no oxygen right it's
it's taken away from your your body so
it changes color because oxygen so
oxygen is actually
extremely important for our life right
it also so hemoglobin actually binds to
oxygen so
now excuse me so hemoglobin is actually
a very very important
protein in your body it carries oxygen
from the lungs to all the tissues
you need oxygen every single cell brings
for breathing you need oxygen so it
carries all this oxygen
and it carries carbon dioxide from the
tissues back
to the lungs for purification correct
and the normal levels each of us
actually have a normal level
of what a hemoglobin should have and i'm
sure some of you have heard oh my god
you're very anemic
which means you don't have enough
hemoglobin so then you put your iron you
need to have
your iron content is low and all of
those things so
hemoglobin is a very very integral
molecule correct
now it consists of four different
polypeptide chains right two alpha
chains and two beta chains
so do you think that the alpha chains
and beta
chains actually come from the same gene
yes or no
no correct they actually come from two
different genes
right and so that's why we take we talk
about two polypeptide chains and did you
know that the definition of a gene
actually has changed in the last 10
years when i went to school
it was the definition of a gene was a
pro l
e gene is something that codes for a
protein
right that is a definition that i was
taught in school
but now i'm sure all of you know that
the definition of a gene has changed
because the gene is something that goes
for a polypeptide
because there are proteins that are
pre-existing like in the pre-form
and you know pre and pro forms and
different chains come together to make a
protein and all of those things so you
know what
that definition has actually changed
right all this data is changing our
minds about understanding different
things right so now you have
it all has a heme group protofor for for
fire and ring and each chain contains a
heme group that carries the oxygen
and of course it contains an iron atom
in the center that actually binds
to the oxygen and a hemoglobin molecule
carries four heme groups and carries
four molecules of oxygen
right it carries it all over the place
now so this is the heme
it's planar and you know oxygen
and d oxygen bound form and not form
and a complex of proto49 and it's a
ferrous
in2 plus is present in the center of the
heme
it binds to four nitrogen atoms of the
ring
right and additional bonds with
histidine residues of globin chain and
it actually binds to oxygen
right so all of this you actually know
right now here
hemoglobin is a great molecular machine
so
what drives most of the protein
interactions
right so hemoglobin i'm telling you
binds to oxygen right
so it has to bind but think about it
does hemoglobin
always stays in oxygen
bound form all the time
does hemoglobin stay does it stay bound
to oxygen all the time
no of course not now you know what there
is a molecule called keras
i'm not sure whether kerstine is
involved in pancreatic cancer
um yeah it it drops it off around the
body that's correct so what happens is
every protein is given a function
and it has to actually do the function
and
so it has an active state and an
inactive state right so every protein in
the cell actually goes through active
state inactive state active state
enactment state
so when it does something it binds um
exactly
so it actually has to switch its roles
right and now hypoglombine may have
other things to do as well right
um and each protein actually has
different functions to play
so it cannot keep doing the same thing
over and over again right so what
happens is
it binds it doesn't bind it binds and so
i call it the active
inactive so there is actually a
hemostasis in the body
where every protein protein binds active
state
and it has to get to in my inactive
state for the next cycle so it's a cycle
right so when something doesn't let go
of something that's when you actually
get diseases and majority of the
diseases the
the the some of the proteins always or
the genes actually always
stay in their activated form for example
in pancreatic cancer
there is a protein called keras or of
course keras is a protein that actually
a gene that is implicated in many
different kinds of
cancers but it is actually very integral
to pancreatic cancer
what happens is it binds to gtp right
a signal comes it binds to gtp you all
know gtp right guanine triphosphate
right one bonus in triphosphate
so gtp binds to gtp and it's an active
state when it binds to hb then something
else comes and hydrolyzes that gtp
to gdp so it's a triphosphate then it
becomes a diphosphate from gtp to gdp
so when it becomes gdp when gtp is
hydrolyzed to gdp then it becomes
inactive
so keras in the in the cell always is
an active inactive active inactive so it
is from gtp to gdp gtp to gdp but what
happens in cancers
it always stays in the gtp form
so it's always activated so then it
actually is always so everything that
cares
all the downstream and upstream proteins
and genes that are dependent on keras
are all gone crazy because they're
waiting for a signal from teras but the
scaras
is not getting hydrolyzed so what
happens it's always in an active form
so what happens is always in an active
form that's what is a problem
right we cannot even design a drug you
know why because the gtp
is binding there and we cannot even bind
anything else there
right so that is the problem so same
thing that hemoglobin
um yeah more active than um
then gtp i'm not sure moiba if i'm
understanding so you mean gtp is more
yeah exactly
gdp you me more active than g dp gdp is
inactive state
right so now what happens is all of them
actually go through a lot of changes
so this hemoglobin molecule just look at
this look at how
so this is the oxygen right so look at
what changes happen
between the oxy state and the deoxy
state
it keeps the whole these domain and this
domain
actually change with respect to each
other right
they keep changing with respect to each
other right so they go through huge
changes with respect to each other right
so that is what happens a lot of stress
conformational changes actually happens
and then there are different types of
hemoglobin right
so this is normal hemoglobin uh and then
this is fetal hemoglobin when a baby
is there we have hemoglobin f it's a
fetal hemoglobin
and oops sorry and then we have a
hemoglobin a1c which is hemoglobin a
when it's glycosylated which means
sugars are added to the hemoglobin and
the levels are very high
and i'm sure that you've heard of a1c
that is being measured in people with
diabetic
right who are diabetic that you're
measuring even sea levels right
then we have abnormal levels of carboxy
hemoglobin
and and all of these things so there are
different types of hemoglobin
and what happens when the hemoglobin
gets into trouble which means it gets
to a mutation right so the genes for the
protein chains of hemoglobin they show
small differences within different human
populations right
so actually you know what between you
and me there are
slight changes but not the function of
course it retains the function
but there are slight changes between you
and me there are some amino acids that
may be different
and differences within human population
right and amino acid sequence of
hemoglobin slightly different from
person to person
and in most cases the changes does not
affect the protein function
and are often are not even even noticed
right we talked about
snips and we talked about a lot of
different things that actually can
be different from different things and
all of those things um and in most cases
actually they do not affect um all of us
right
and they we won't even notice that there
are changes in hemoglobin right
and in some cases these different amino
acids lead to major structural changes
so one such example of a major change
which you all know is actually
sickle cell anemia where there is one
mutation
uh from a glutamic acid to a baleen
and do you know why now that you know
the properties of some of these amino
acids
you know all these structural elements
and all of those things
so why do you think one single mutation
has actually caused such a major change
in a structure
and hence it's causing a disease right
so say for example i'm gonna ask you
this question say that
instead of a glutamic acid
say that it mutated to an aspartic acid
do you think you would still say this
see the same dramatic change in the
protein structure
why is changing a glutamic acid to
available
so you know it's causing so much of
problems
any ideas um the hydrophobicity
uh so okay so you mean that valine is
more hydrophobic
than aspartic i mean glutamic acid um
and then uh no because both are acidic
ah
actually baleen is actually a
hydrophobic amino acid
it's actually not an acetic acid and
then
it affects the helix yes it affects the
healings i actually actually told you
right
it does affect the helix um that is
actually correct
uh binding of oxygen site is of course
if you already know that that change but
i'm asking
why glutamic acid to
valine is so pronounced just focus on
those two amino acids and the properties
of just those two amino acids
oh yes okay good supplement yeah yeah
thanks for the clarification yeah you're
absolutely correct you're absolutely
correct
so tell me just focus on aspartic acid
glutamic acid and valine
let's look at the properties of this
glutamic acid
is actually a negatively charged amino
acid
right it's because pka is around 4.3
or something like that but availing on
the other side
is actually a very hydrophobic amino
acid
so you are actually disrupting
the complete charge distribution by just
this one
amino acid from a charge to an
uncharged so it's a huge change
and i think that's more you said i think
it is perfecting the
of the distribution of the hill is out
this three-dimensional positioning of
the helices so
what happened is this change in one
region of the protein
has affected a lot of different regions
in the other parts of the protein
right and so yes in majority of the
diseases it is just one amino acid that
can actually
disrupt based on what that a particular
amino acid is
right so now this is a phylogenetic tree
of all the different families
of hemoglobin that we know right
so you can actually see there are so
many different
families of hemoglobin in different
species and different things right but
of course
having said that all of them are
conserved in their function all of them
are conserved in the region that
actually does the
oxygen binding and all of those things
if you do that but these are small small
changes
in other parts of hemoglobin there are
different changes so you can actually
see
that there are so many different um
uh you know families of all of these
things
now you all know about sickle cell
anemia right one such example that with
this one single you already know
glutamate right
so it's actually changing in
one base change and then it is giving
from normal protein it is actually
giving a sickled protein what is
happening is
the structure of hemoglobin is actually
changing
it becomes sickled the mutation allows
the deoxygenated form of ego hemoglobin
to actually stick to each other and it
produces
the fibers of hemoglobin inside the
blood right so
you know what so it causes it's not able
to
bind to oxygen there is not enough
oxygen
the other red blood cells are sickled
like
this right from this shape
it all becomes this shape
right so isn't that amazing right so all
of this
as it's going it becomes sickled and
this
in turns what happens is it deforms the
red blood cells
which normally is a very smooth disc
shape and it becomes a sickle shape
right
and these distorted cells are fragile
and often rupture
leading to the loss of hemoglobin right
so what happens the loss of hemoglobin
you become anemic
right and anemia is actually a serious
disease
it's actually fatal anemia is very very
fatal you can die from
being anemic right so that's why uh it's
very
serious and interestingly a lot of this
um um sickle cell anemia is very
prevalent
in countries uh like asia and africa and
all of those places
hot places it's very a very thing right
but then you know what um in diseases
we've noticed there are more than couple
of examples right
so um can we compare the fibers
to her um i am not sure i
understand your question superna when
you are talking about
actin uh and its relevance to sickle
cell
um um can you elaborate i just don't
know
um hold on that question okay and we'll
just open up for
questioning and then we can actually um
you know
all of those things information out
there that our basis are sickle that's
protected
yeah exactly so movie why you stole my
thunder right now
that is exactly what i wanted to talk
about right
so majority of uh some of these
mutations
you know what happens is it causes one
disease
but then it is protecting you from
another disease so it is almost like we
have to
pick and choose which disease we want
right
so people with sickle cell anemia are
they're protected by
they won't get malaria right again there
are so many examples where
one disease people with one disease are
actually
you know they're protected so i think
that um
people with uh you know uh i can't think
of there are several examples that i
was just in my head right now so there
are several examples of
how one can protect you against another
disease
right i think even um
people with the um receptor for ebola
that's like blanking actually are
protected again human newman pick
disease people with pneumonia disease
actually are protected from getting
ebola
right so you know what but there are
lots of
and then there are people with with some
polymorphisms are protected against
inflammation
right so some of this you know actually
cause one disease but then they protect
you
protecting you against another disease
so i'm not sure if that's a good thing
or a bad thing
uh you know i don't know which one you
would pick uh there's a cure for malaria
so i just don't know how you think about
this so
you know what and what does it mean and
the same gene is implicated
implicated in multiple diseases right so
we are going to be talking more about
those things as we're doing the hands-on
so i think i'm almost at the end so
all i want to convince you today and the
take-home message for you today
is structure defines function um have i
actually convinced you the structure is
important
and have i actually convinced you that
structure yes thank you betsy
uh actually i am yes fantastic and
structure is very important for function
without structures we can have a life
you know what i mean ah and so now
uh essentially good thank you very much
now i'm going to
in the next five to seven minutes
that we have i'm going to answer some of
your questions and then maybe i'll walk
you through what to expect for tomorrow
and what you can be prepared for
tomorrow
okay so i'm gonna get back to um one of
the questions that i actually did not
answer
um okay super now so um
okay so what was the question i think
oh okay since hemoglobin fibers
deform the rbc's in sickle cell anemia
can we compare this to the way that
actin fibers
affect the shape of a normal um yes
when you're talking about the
interaction that happens in a
fiber right so the patterns of
interaction that happens in a fiber even
alzheimer's right you actually have
um which are myeloid fibers so when you
talk about fibers
we are just talking about
oligomerization
of these protein 100 fold right that's
pretty much what we're talking about
right so yeah in terms of comparison you
actually can compare
yeah because fibers are more
uh what you call it gives the shape and
all of those things so in that sense
absolutely correct you you can compare
them if that's what you're trying to do
yes
if i'm isolating a new protein and want
to know the structure
so you okay so it's a long haul so if
you want to isolate a protein
the steps involved in from protein to a
structure
is um you know many different steps
are involved first you have to purify
your protein
when i say purify your protein that
means you have to purify your protein
200
which means when you run a gel of your
protein
it is just a single band not only that
it should have only one isolated species
so you need a highly highly highly super
pure protein for crystallography
right once you purify the protein you
have to find conditions to
set up crystallization of this protein
so you have to crystallize this protein
and if you are lucky if you have a green
thumb then once you have crystals then
you take these crystals and you have to
find an x-ray machine to put these
crystals in an x-ray diffracter
machine it's a huge machine and then you
collect data and then from that data
it is like a long haul there are so many
different steps that are involved from
taking a protein from
purifying to a three-dimensional
structure right
um if you're interested i can meet with
you one-on-one to walk you over the
detail steps because it's a it's a lot
to explain right now
but i'm you know i'm happy to give you
there are like five six major steps
involved in taking a protein from
sequence to structure
yes if the purity if the purity is not
great i would not even attempt to
crystallize because it's not going to
work
if the protein is not pure don't even
attempt
nothing is going to come it's going to
be a waste of your time
right okay so now um
any other questions um
is there any concept that um i talked
about that just went over your head
that i can you know talk or you know
spend a minute or two
uh if there are any questions um that i
can answer
uh please let me know i'm sure you're
all tired and exhausted i'm just
so excited with this group very
interactive group
amazing group um and i'm very thankful
for that so if i'm isolating and you
want to
uh bulges besides for um can bulges
besides for drug binding
yes um yeah sure why not
um but it is a case-by-case basis so
it's not like a blanket statement that i
can say that bulges are
every bulge you can target to find
something it all depends on the context
of that particular protein
so you can explore that because bulges
come up with me very
you know usually most of them are
actually on the interfaces so
we do look at them um
in the example to study all a lot of
antibody antigen interactions
actually have bulges antibodies act as
structures that i actually have solved
in my life for my phd actually had a
bulge
so when we see bulges we make a big deal
out of that yes i've seen
bulges in my own so antibodies are
because antibodies have a higher content
of tryptophans than any other protein so
we see a lot of bulges and
antibody loops hypervariable groups of
antibodies
um so i don't think um so the
i am i'm not sure um
there is no need um actually super
enough for having the bulges for protein
structure
but we just see them because for example
if there is a bulky amino acid residue
for
some reason is in the middle of a strand
the it disrupts the hydrogen bonding
pattern so what happens is it's almost
like an extra amino acid in that
particular strand
right so there is no hydrogen bonding
pattern for it so what happens is it
ends up just
kinking and bulging based on the
five-side angles that it actually has
that's all
more the other than that there is
nothing more to these bulges right
there are lots of ruby articles on these
bulges but um it's not that the protein
requires
pulses it's just the other way around
that the evolution by if
nature has created them like that like
that right
um and in some cases at least in my case
of the structure that i solved
i found a functional consequence of that
particular bulge in way it interacted
with the peptide antigen that i was
actually studying
right so it made a very strong um
salt bridge with the antigen that i was
studying so it's a case by case basis
right okay uh gene was it because
what's um uh so a gene is actually
something that codes for a polypeptide
that's what we
we define a gene right now that it codes
for a polypeptide instead of a protein
okay so um
okay so now let me go and see if i'm not
answered any other question
can you please explain the need for
bulges okay explain that
um the need okay did i miss anything
um you said parallel strands
don't exist in proteins yes exactly
that's correct megan parallel sets
do not extend as i told you uh it's not
energetically favorable to have parallel
strands
uh in the sense of that but there may be
short stretches in a protein that could
be parallel
so i would say that it's an exception to
the rule rather than
the norm and so the norm anti-parallel
stance
okay so any other questions um
do you all have of course i'm here with
you for you know
um another uh week or so so
um we can see if you have any other
questions you can actually
you know um bring it up in the next
couple of
days and you can review this and
if something comes up right so um
possible state will that be explained um
i'm not talking i'm not sure perimela
which graph
you're talking about
um what is a pure protein a pure protein
merissa means
uh that you just see one band on your
jaw
that means it's just one species one
form of species in your entire
suspension
for designing a research product analyze
a protein what should we look for to
make sure
it actually works um so when you're
talking
about uh jeffrey if you're talking about
uh for designing a research product to
analyze a protein watch
so um for your research project um
if you're talking about you know i
picking up an interesting
protein for research i would pick to see
whether the protein actually has a
three-dimensional structure because then
you can do a lot more with it
but the structure is actually has a
bound ligand um
that is even more better because you can
analyze ligand interactions
then you can actually look at structures
that are implicated in a disease
and then it's even more interesting to
figure out why that
um you know why that protein is
implicated in the disease and even more
if there are some polymorphisms that
have been found
to be correlated with that particular
disease so this is the rule of thumb
that i tell my students
uh for my course for them to do their
projects i tell them pick a structure
that has a ligand bound because protein
that's implicated in a disease
like a protein where there's a lot of
literature that is known so that you can
actually
you know look at things um and you know
at least the biochemistry of it is
worked out right
now um
i for email are you talking about
something that i showed today
or in i don't even remember but we can
get back to it tomorrow
so you just tell me whether i talked
about it today
did i show a graph today um
[Music]
i am not sure but let me um you can you
can tell me whether it was today was it
today
uh
along with ramachandran plot okay
okay i will look into it and i'll get
back to you tomorrow because we are
running out of time today but
can you remind me tomorrow if you're
going to be there tomorrow you can
remind me tomorrow
um and i will because i may
end up forgetting but then you can
actually tell me tomorrow you bring it
up and then we will address that i will
look to see if the slides
actually had any graph and i can explain
that to you tomorrow
yes um i guess that's it from me um
beep shot did you do you have anything
um no i don't have anything to add i
just wanted to uh walk everyone through
once more
to the organization page before we go
i think um that will be helpful
okay so
i can share my screen
and i just wanted you all to just see uh
the organization page
and where you can find the different
resources
so this is the genomics in a virtual lab
organization page now you see
in this forum section we have posted all
the different topics
uh that will be covered or you will have
a problem with
so under this topic session recordings
and video tutorials you will see that
uh the video of the first session has
been posted
so if you don't see that email which
i've already sent to you
you can also refer to this section right
here
so i will also post today's recording
here
and you can continue to see the
different resources when you go through
the courses
if you have any problems with the
pipelines you can post it around here
so i'll be sharing this link again
and also we keep on posting about top
performers of the week
so that is something that i want you all
to see and
update your profiles so what does an
updated profile look like
sorry to interrupt now uh we have
another meeting so i have to start that
meeting so it's on my zoom
so i think we are also exceeded time so
if yeah
thank you so much for the wonderful
lecture it was like very
intriguing and learned so much so many
things thank you so much
yeah thank you yeah okay guys have a
good day good night
and thank you everyone please update
your profiles okay
thank you so much
bye everyone bye-bye
thank you dr sona yeah thank you
bye bye